1000 for all hey guys so we just reached
over 1000 subscribers on YouTube the
other day and we decided to do a special
1000 subscriber video just to thank you
all for supporting us and kind of to let
you know what we got going on in the
future um you got something to say goes
in thanks guys so much I still you know
seems unreal we have a thousand
subscribers who actually want to watch
what we're doing which is pretty awesome
yeah we're pretty huge no man I'm saying
like we're pretty sure we're getting
like fan mail like I'm actually gonna
read some of the fan mail we've been
getting like like we're being recognized
the street yeah man like Brad Pitt the
other day was like bro you're the guy
from YouTube but no okay so let me just
read you some of the family got okay so
the first one first one you want the
Nigerian lottery okay so now that I
think that will spam but it was when I
saw here marry a beautiful russian no
that's that's not okay how about would
you like to have a bigger okay so we
don't really have fan mail I don't think
yet but we just want to say we really do
appreciate all the nice comments we've
been getting from you guys the words of
encouragement the fact that you've been
subscribing and supporting us like it
means a lot and it keeps us going we
love doing this we have fun doing it but
I did one but the fact that we have
people actually supporting us and
actually encouraging us like that means
a lot man for sure we would we'd be
doing this like if we had zero
subscribers but the fact that saw you
guys look what you're doing it's how you
love or were doing and so you're
consistently commenting that means the
world to us and we're very thankful for
that yeah and we got a bunch of stuff
coming off a much more content like the
comedy skits that we've been doing have
been um we've received really positive
feedback for that and we're gonna keep
doing that keep improving with those oh
we're going to be doing reviews we were
going to be looking more into manga just
because I'm a big reader so I'm gonna be
reviewing more
got in the upcoming weeks and months so
look out for that we're not gonna limit
ourselves to anime only yeah absolutely
and uh yeah so we've also got we're
going to be doing some Pokemon go
logging because it's just the biggest
thing ever right now ok guys so check
out some of these awesome comments real
comments not Russian bride comments that
that we actually have gotten and we
really appreciate yeah thanks so much
guys this is this means a lot to us keep
it going keep it coming if you like our
stuff share it we really appreciate it
stick around stay tuned and we'll see
you space cowboys
you